why is it important that the hero
experience false hope Oh false hope is a
very necessary point in the hero's
journey the protagonist journey because
without it there won't be a context for
the surrender at the end of the second
act okay so let me give you an example
let's say I'm trying to think of a story
well let's let's just let's just say a
character let's say I want Sally to love
me so I'll be complete okay
the false hope is the moment where I
have a first date with Sally and we kiss
and yes I'm gonna get what I want
but what I want is for Sally to love me
but the reason I want it is so that I'll
be complete okay so the false hope is
it's sort of like going to Vegas and
putting a nickel in the slot and a dime
comes out and you go by midnight I'll be
a millionaire I just doubled my money
and then the next day you leave town on
a greyhound that's the the false hope is
the misperception the protagonist has
about their situation okay what the the
the the false hope is where the
protagonist is not yet aware that that
what they're struggling with is not a
problem it's a dilemma they think
they've got a problem they don't they've
got a dilemma okay and so so that's what
the false hope is okay without the false
hope no context for the surrender we
don't understand what they're
surrendering because the protagonist
isn't surrender I'm not surrendering my
desire for Sally at the end of the
second act I'm surrendering I'm letting
go of the realization that as long as I
believe that Sally will complete me I'm
I'm screwed okay so that's I'm
surrendering the meaning I make out of
my goal I'm not surrendering my goal the
goal never goes away I never stopped
wanting Sally to love me by the way this
Billy Crystal's POV and one Harry Met
Sally no no I'm just picturing
the restaurant scene okay I'm just using
you're just using right salary outs just
I always I don't know why I was talking
about Sally and my sure it's like a
codependent relationship and you're
you're thinking that this person is
going to complete you and anymore
whatever it is it could be about if the
theme is if the theme is freedom you
know I was talking about the the prison
I have to let go of the belief that
escape will lead to freedom if it's
justice I have to let go of the false
belief that so the false hope let's say
let's say my stories about justice I
want justice they screwed me over I'm
gonna get revenge the false hope is yes
revenge is within my reach okay that
would be that that would be the false
hope moment the surrender would be the
realization that an eye for an eye
leaves the whole world blind okay so the
end of Act two there is no such thing as
justice through revenge you know and
then I might discover the Justice comes
through a wider perspective perhaps
compassion you know understanding my
situation in a new way that makes sense
so the false hope is is where I believe
that I believe that through revenge I
will justice will be meted out
you